The Joe Rogan Experience I guess this is
an opportunity to bring up Jeff Epstein
so you know people sometimes wonder you
know like we're scientists you know you
know hanging out with him to get you
know to get with these young women or
something I know scientists there are
some scientists like that they were
spending time with him because he was
giving their Laboratories money yeah
that they didn't have to write grants
for why was he doing that though oh
there are very strong opinions he under
I never met him I know people who knew
him
um but he clearly understood
social engineering he understood that
rich people have they can get anything
they want anything they want except the
one thing they can't easily control is
their reputation because that requires
other people's perceptions and just
being rich doesn't make you necessarily
respected by certain people yes by
certain people no so he understood that
very wealthy people will feel more
important
and can derive more sense of
self-respect when they are surrounded by
brilliant people and he was very good at
bringing truly brilliant people into
that mix people like Murray Gilman who
discovered the Quark right he's a
particle physicist I mean head of the
Santa Fe Institute Nobel Prize I mean
he's Gilman used to pick on Richard
Feynman he was one of the few people who
could maybe not verbally joust with him
but at a scientific level could could
pin that guy so they were on more or
less equal tier but fine you know Gail
man was right up there so Epstein
understood like bring around the the gel
mans bring around the top genetic
researchers from Harvard
by doing that he made these rich people
feel like they were in the company of
interesting important people interesting
and why would scientists spend time with
rich people I'll be really honest I do a
lot of work for uh these days for
talking about science and and trying to
generate science philanthropy that's a
big part of my life now trying to
generate money to give to studies that
are really interesting and valid we
could talk about that if you like
scientists will show up to dinners that
normally they'd rather be in their Labs
or writing grants or with their families
frankly if there's the possibility of
money being given to their laboratory
because then they can hire more people
and do more science money alone doesn't
drive good science but the more money
you have the bigger margin of error you
have so if Epstein offers offered
Laboratories you know a million dollars
a year for four years to a guy of that
wealth as trivial to a laboratory that
is four National Institutes of Health
Grants per year and that workload to
maintain those four grants is immense so
they'd show up with the possibility of
getting money that's where they were
hanging out with a dirt bag like him and
they they had blinders on either they
knew or they didn't know what he was up
to but they had blinders on because they
weren't thinking about the implications
well it's also one of the things about
something like that must be that if you
go there and you see Stephen Pinker and
you see Lawrence Krauss and you see Bill
Gates it seems like you should be there
it seems fine to be there also on you
know Sinister diabolical narcissistic
and sociopathic but brilliant social
engineering on the part events yeah he
understood that they felt comfortable in
the room because of who else was there
yeah rich people like will show up to a
place for who's not there as we know
they like to have space right and
scientists generally don't like to
hobnob it's not really their thing what
they like to do is work on their pet
projects they're they're a little bit
like comedians they're in the sense that
they have a craft they want to be
working on they're only going to to do
things like go out and get money if they
have to get money and they do a lot to
get money well I'm sure there's a social
aspect of It sharing around with other
brilliant scientists at a wonderful
place you have good food and drink and
there's pretty girls around yeah but
it's probably exciting it's probably
exciting although I think that at some
level scientists real scientists died in
the world scientists would rather just
be doing science I'm sure I mean I mean
this is a very rare occasion I'm sure
that they're doing this so yeah there's
a thing that's Harvard sure yeah I mean
he kind of he ingratiated himself in
this community he just understood it was
sort of like I do some work with some
professional sports teams right and the
only people that they look up to are
tier one special operators you tell a
pro MBA player like oh in the NFL they
do this they're like whatever you tell
them that you know this will increase
your your output by 10 they're like
whatever they don't care they want to
play video games they do not care they
want to hang out with their girlfriend
or their four girlfriends whatever it is
you tell them tier one operators who do
high-risk High consequence work and are
on deployment schedules that would
dissolve you into a puddle of your own
tears because it's a vampire schedule
you don't get to sleep when you want to
and you get you potentially die you
potentially all die and their running
times are faster their recovery times
are faster their shooting accuracy is
far better than your shooting actors and
that's with a gun and getting shot at
and they go okay I'll listen they look
up to tier one operators that's a fact
and so if you want them to listen you
understand that fact you look at what
tier one operators are doing that's what
professional sports teams are trying to
glean that information
billionaires they have different
interests obviously they some race
Yachts some what you know want to start
new projects but they want to be around
really Innovative interesting people and
in Academia there are a very small
subset of those running big Laboratories
and Epstein just got that down to the
detail and then he understood I think
with politicians they can their
reputations are everything and so he
gave them a vaulted world where they
could behave how they wanted I mean in
some sense I mean he his story is one of
of multiple psychologies not just his
yeah that's why people that have studied
him and the whole case believe that and
from other evidence and information as
well that he was part of some sort of an
intelligence operation and there was
compromising these people oh I'm sure
that at some point he had information on
other people and he just used it as yeah
as a and it doesn't have to be strong
hand blackmail right he could just say
you know
we've got information we'll hold it
secure well you would just you don't
even have to Blackmail someone if you
know they have information on you and
they have not used it you will act in
their best interest to try to get them
on your good side
well I mean in the in the unraveling of
the all the the dark sordid around
um Weinstein it was discovered I think
in New York like in near that Avenue
down in Alphabet City police uh Precinct
um it turns out that there were you know
a boatload of files that date back ages
and you know there were it's not that
cops are corrupt it's that they're
incentivized by certain things too and
their bosses were telling them you got
to do certain things you got to put away
certain files and you know people are
trying to make careers I I think that's
why that show it's a little outdated now
but um from technology standpoint but
the wire was so brilliant is that every
aspect of that was a human endeavor and
science is a human endeavor and I I
we're kind of paying attention to the
the darker unfortunate side they're also
I again I always feel like I got a shine
light where it belongs to which is that
a lot of amazing science is happening
because of excellent philanthropy of
people that are not pedophiles yes right
of course and those people you know and
but let's be honest walk onto any
University campus look at the names on
the sides of the buildings do you think
they're there to honor those people
because those were great people
sometimes they're great people they're
there because those people donated 50 to
100 million dollars right I mean and
this has been known in in law schools
and business schools for a long time
because you'd see it on this that was it
kind of more accepted there because it's
business and law right right but if you
walk onto any campus I don't care if
it's UT Austin or Stanford or it's
Harvard the names on those sides of
buildings sometimes it's the Kennedy
building sometimes it's the Rockefeller
building more often than not these are
names of people you don't recognize
anymore and names of people don't even
live in the United States they gave 100
million dollars for a building that
trains medical students universities are
a business too
100 and it doesn't mean that they're
trying to corrupt anybody but they have
to survive you've got to pay the janitor
yeah yeah pay the cops you get on the
campus I mean so it is a business and I
think you that's the Human Side actually
to your credit I learned from you we I
think you may or may not remember but a
few years ago we were talking about
everything that was going on in the
public health thing and you're like the
reason I'm curious about this and I
don't trust this these were your words
more or less was because
I know about people and that's at the
end of the day it's all about people in
their psychology